a quick glance at the clock means time
for the press preview a first look at
the front pages
as they arrive time to see what's making
the headlines with the new statesman's
deputy online editor rachel cunliffe and
the deputy editor of spiked online tom
slater
more from them in just a moment but
let's uh take a look at the front pages
that we have
starting with the daily mirror and of
course splashing with the birth of
lillibit diana prince harry and megan's
new daughter
the metro remarks on the newborn's name
being a nod to the queen
with this headline gran gesture
daily star having a little bit of fun
with the baby's first name
the headline woman has little baby
the telegraph meanwhile reporting that
the health secretary has admitted
it might just be necessary to push back
the scheduled loosening of covert
restrictions on the 21st of june
if data over the next week heads in the
wrong direction
compare and contrast though the male
urging conservative back benches to
lobby mr hancock
not to delay reopening any further
here's the times it says british
holidaymakers face chaos
at airports and testing sites as they
rush to try and make it back to the uk
from portugal
the guardian though reporting on
warnings that yesterday's global
corporate tax deal
has a loophole that could allow amazon
to escape paying significantly more tax
and a shortage of chips no not my dinner
instead little things
inside electrical products that's
fueling concerns over the availability
of cars
and other consumer goods according to
the ft
as mentioned we're joined tonight by
rachel cunliffe and tom slater
lovely to see the pair of you and plenty
for us to chat so tom
let's dive straight on and take us to
the front of the daily telegraph their
headline there
matt hancock hinting at a delay to
reopening
i would say he's doing rather more than
a gentle hint in fact
most certainly i mean today when he was
doing mediocre he
said that the government was essentially
open to the question
of delaying the june 21st reopening
this is the first time we've really
heard such language i think i'm writing
saying so far you've heard the
government very much sticking to the
line
that there's nothing that they see in
the data at the moment and for things
to have to be changed or held back boris
wasn't saying that even last week but
still just kind of hedging their butt
their bets and waiting for more
information to come in in this piece you
can see various different scientific
advisors giving their view
many of them urging caution but i think
it's fair to say across a lot of the
certainly the right leaning papers
tonight
a lot of pushback as well at the idea
that all of these months in
that the road map should be delayed
despite the indian variant things are
looking very
seem to be a fair bit i mean rachel just
just sticking with the telegraph for a
second
isn't this in a sense though a bit of a
statement of the obvious
the data we are told is constantly under
review the june 21st date is still a few
weeks
away wouldn't they always have been
looking at the data to make sure that
reopening on june 21st was
was going to be possible well it's the
contradiction isn't it between
what boris johnson said uh right at the
beginning of the roadmap relying on
dates
not dates i having those dates uh pen
the earliest possible dates for
unlocking but moving forward looking at
later and checking the unlocking could
go ahead at those
speakers unfortunately the way the
government particularly prime minister
has been acting over the past couple of
months those dates really have become
uh deadlines rather than target and a
huge
expectation for business for uh society
especially
among members rests on that june the
21st date so backing
backtracking on it now will make the
government look like
a failure particularly if it has been
driven by the the indian variant
when the the government refused to put
india on on the red list until
two weeks after uh the the awareness of
the
of that strain was was growing in the uk
so it's it's a problem for the
government particularly because
if this does get delayed it will make it
look like boris johnson is is personally
liable which is obviously responsibility
that he has so far managed to avoid
i think what the government's waiting to
see with um the the increase in
in transmission in cases is whether that
leads to
the the two-week lag an increase in
hospitalizations and sadly
deaths as we've seen with other waves or
if the vaccine rollout is now at a point
where
yes cases can rise the r number can go
above one but enough people have been
vaccinated they're hoping sixty percent
of adults vaccinated by june 21st with
um
with two jabs uh infinitely more with
with having at least one whether that is
enough to break the link between
a high number of cases and
hospitalizations i'm tom i mean the the
front of the tomorrow's daily mail i
mean don't
wobble now ministers as the article
makes clear some of the pressure in fact
coming from
the people that sit behind the prime
minister let's let's just leave to
one side matt hancock saying that you
know the the link has been severed
but not broken i mean i i don't know if
he's got a different definition of
severed from me
um but but do you think that when it
comes to making a decision about
reopening on the 21st
there will be political concerns in the
prime minister's mind as much as
anything else
there will definitely be political
concerns and also at the end of the day
even though the government has like to
lean on the scientists to say that
they're following the quote
science there are trade-offs in all of
this there are
questions that can't really just be
answered purely by the data
as we're often being presented we're
weighing up the potential threat
of again a rising cases against the
questions of
the very real costs of lockdown i think
it's just important to
remember that in terms of where we are
with the virus at the moment
not only do we have this remarkable
vaccine roll out but
when the roadmap was first set out sage
modeled all kinds of different scenarios
as to what they thought would happen
particularly as you say with
hospitalizations because
with kobe that's really what we've got
to worry about are people in the upper
hospital
are people ending up seriously or are
people tragically dying
and the number of daily admissions to
hospital at the moment are below
sage's best case scenario we're in a
very very good situation
and i think what many of the papers as
you said the daily mail leave the charge
there are calling for
is for boris johnson to listen to the
good news and to get us back to normal
because
loads of people across the country
really need that not just for the
economy state but for their own
well-being
um again rachel let's just stick with
this for a second i mean there will be
people who disagree with those tory back
benchers saying look we've got to reopen
no matter what on june the 21st but even
quoted in the article one of them
desmond swain says this you know the
more the government moves the goalposts
the more people will be made redundant i
mean that is a statement of fact
isn't it uh it is a statement of fact
particularly in
industries like hospitality and
entertainment and large events
that have been effectively completely
shut down for the past
15 months and uh gearing up towards this
day
as government support uh has been
limited
all of their business plans all of the
the plans for the survival of their comp
and are based on on that date and i
think
andrew lloyd webber was talking about
potentially suing the government if they
missed that day
just simply because the business costs
are and the risks are
are so high and i think uh there's also
a kind of
public awareness vaccine while so
successful we've had very low
vaccine hesitancy in this country
compared to what we've seen
in other countries and if you start
moving
the goal as assessment says there and
you start telling people that yes you
got your vaccine
and uh you've got both your jab and
everyone you know got both your jabs
but we still can't open as planned even
though we promised that was what we
would
do that's going to cause political
pressure among the public not just in
the in the tory party
so it really the law of actually looking
at um
the the link between rising cases and
civilizations
because if you can see that the
increasing case
isn't leading into extra pressure on the
nhs and pressure on hospitals
then the unlocking can can go ahead
regardless of whether cases are still
relatively high
um tom i mean the tony back benches are
are quite busy these days i mean the
front of the guardian suggests that you
know there's a there could be will be a
vote tomorrow on or on
foreign aid and indeed from what i hear
a vote they could well
the government could well lose yes this
is one of the striking things about this
parliament i think because you have that
atc majority but because i think as a
result of brexit
in part because of all of the kind of
parliamentary maneuverings and
coalitions that that created the um
tory back benches are far more
rebellious than they are even usually
like uh willing to land blows against
the government
again it's not necessarily just a kind
of small group of awkward squad mps and
we've seen that on covet issues we've
seen on brexit issues certainly
previously
and now we're seeing it focus on this
question of foreign aid and the guardian
picking up on this particular
line of attack they have which is urging
the government not to
use the plans to transfer or excess
vaccines to kind of make up
for the two percent difference in
foreign aid as a result of this for an
aid cut
but yes it's a striking fact in this
parliament is that in any other era an
atc majority would be something
that a government could really sit
pretty on but time and again we see
that that majority can disappear very
quickly if your mps are in a rebellious
move
i mean rachel what are you hearing in
terms of the in terms of the vote in
parliament
as i said someone very senior spoke to
me a little bit earlier on tonight
and they think they've got it i'm not
surprised because it's so many
different factions of of tory rebels
here you've got tori's who
uh really believe in the pledge and
international development of
particularly
minister former former ministers who
have worked in that department and can
see
the good that that money can do you've
got the global britain crowd who really
believe
that post brexit of britain should be
leading the way on the world stage
and part of that is having a real
presence in in global development
and making sure that it's britain
leading in in developing nations and
not necessarily leaving a gap for
countries like say china
to to swoop in and having global
influence in that way
um it's it's tories who don't
particularly care uh
but who believe that it's a manifesto
pledge and therefore it's part of their
professional political
integrity and then it's also anyone who
just doesn't like boris johnson and
would love the chance to
to inflict a defeat on on his government
so you've got
a huge variety of factions with the
rebels
here and i think the chance to send
a message to the prime minister perhaps
to signal their dissatisfaction
with all kinds of things that have been
going on in in government in the past
year
that's probably part of it too so
definitely want to watch very closely
i'm i've got to say let's stick with the
front page of the guardian tom
um it's been a long time since i was
under 30 so
i'm going to have to tap your experience
in all of this do you think getting
stickers and bonuses on dating apps is
likely to make young people
take the vaccination i'm not sure about
that the department of health apparently
might differ
as far as it is teaming up with all of
the big dating apps tinder
match hinge bumble etcetera to try and
actually say i'm incentivize
people on these apps into getting the
jab i guess
to you would be able to show that you're
quote unquote safe
once you've already had the vaccination
so it's all part of this obviously this
discussion to try
and encourage young people who are
obviously you know have a vanishingly
small chance of getting seriously ill
and dying with the virus
but nevertheless for the sake of keeping
a lid on transmissions urging them
to get vaccinated in my mind i think
it's more about just making the argument
to people rather than trying to do these
little
inducements and that and sticker
campaigns on dating apps are not 100
sure but shows the
concern that's definitely government
about whether or not the under 30s will
take the vaccine when they're called up
for a lot of anxiety about that
yeah um rachel what's your view i have
to admit i'm just looking at some of the
names of these uh dating apps and i've
never even heard a half of them but
what's your view i've tried most of them
with
limited success i must say i think my
most successful dating app is definitely
twitter um i do find it slightly
distasteful the idea of
signaling your health status on on a
dating app people being that
public about quite intimate personal
health details i mean
it makes sense from a vaccination
campaign i just i wouldn't like to see
it with
anything else i prefer the um uh the
strategy in
various u.s states where they've had
bars offering free beer if you get a
vaccine no one offered me a free
anything
when i got when i got mine and i would
very much have appreciated her
thank you for getting a vaccine here's a
gnt although you know the drink aware
are saying you're not meant to drink
after them
so not sure about that but yeah free
beer
or lottery ticket entry rather than
dating app stickers definitely the way
to go
uh welcome back to the press preview uh
tom and rachel still
taking us through the stories of the day
um
this is an interesting one and rach
let's come to you first the royal
birth a story which if you're on social
media appeared to divide people into
three camps
complete excitement complete
indifference or utter
outrage at the front of the daily mirror
into which camp does it fall
i think that's that that's a fairly
standard there is
a new member of the royal family i don't
think that it
is it's sort of playing into the uh
manufactured culture wars that we have
to have every time harry and megan do
do anything like the royal family is is
an institution this child is now
i think eighth in line to the throne
possibly displacing prince andrew
maybe just a reminder that prince andrew
is still a member of the royal family
um and it is going to be he's going to
be covered in some way
they've picked a name which has family
resident resonance that's fine too
uh that's about as excited as i can get
about this and i think that the mirror
sort of
reflects that we have to acknowledge it
it's happened this child
now exists congratulations to them we
can leave it back
i like that this child now exists lily
as we should call her no
not lily tom let's leave aside the fact
i still can never understand this
phenomenon of people naming their child
one thing and then
calling it another thing but the front
of the daily star they're they're having
perhaps slightly more fun uh with this
than some of the other papers
yes the ever irreverent style they're
saying woman has a little
baby and with slightly less fanfare as
you see what you see
elsewhere as a republican i struggle to
get excited even about the royal babies
which are people who
still work in the royal family i tend to
be more on kind of team daily star if
you like on this particular issue
not particularly interesting but as
we're actually saying these things are
of significance
unfortunately because of the fact we
still have a monarchy so these people do
have power
influence um from birth essentially so
that's why
naturally all these things do become a
big story whenever
a new child exists as rachel put it
um well i have to say lilly is a very
nice name so and i think uh if we ended
on a positive note that is probably for
the best uh
we will see you both a little bit later
in fact at half past eleven uh for now
though thanks very much indeed